it's almost like uh can't beat them join
them but they're still trying to beat
them to a certain degree and it's by
going even further
what okay
what do we do about this is there
anything and how can you be on the pro
ai side here
ai does have a bunch of benefits when
it's designed for human values and not
for the technocracy and the oligarchs
who are you know trying to control
everything or sorry
mostly do control everything now this
question of whether ai rules is
scientific and headline grabbing but
actually kind of uninteresting the
really interesting question is
the tech of ai which is much more
mundane and down to earth but actually
changing the world as we speak
welcome to episode 144 of the michaela
peterson podcast i'm michaela peterson
with tree allergies sorry i didn't give
you guys a podcast last week i had no
voice now my voice is kind of back this
might be what i sound like forever we
will see this is an opposing views
episode where i interviewed two people
with vastly different views on a subject
this episode was about artificial
intelligence
in this episode of opposing views we
discussed the existential risk of ai job
automation mass surveillance deep
learning government ai and the ex-ceo of
google pushing for facial recognition
and social credit systems in america my
first guest was the entrepreneur
filmmaker podcast host and author andrew
keane
andrew also hosts the award-winning
documentary and tv show how to fix
democracy
although he wasn't exactly optimistic
about fixing america
my second guest was stephen umbrello the
managing director at the institute for
ethics and emerging technologies and
editor of ethics and robotics steven
holds a phd in the ethics and design of
a.i he's the one who told me about the
ex google ceo and what america has
planned for its citizens
let me know who you found more
convincing in the comments section or
perhaps both guests are right
this episode was sponsored by schweink
grylls do you remember the best steak
you've ever had
or are you one of those poor suckers
that thinks steaks are supposed to be
gray well i'm here to tell you there's
hope for you let me introduce
schweinkrill's 1500 degree portable
infrared grill these things make anyone
look like a natural they're made in
america and the parts are all stainless
steel that slide out for easy washing it
even comes with a pizza stone for people
who still eat pizza
no pizza isn't healthy even in
moderation sorry but you're still gonna
do it so they sent a pizza stone
these girls are perfect for any deck
patio or backyard and they cook with the
same infrared technology used in
professional kitchens like morton's
steakhouse
if you want to impress people or if you
make your steaks gray anyways get one of
these they're amazing schwank has a
great deal for my listeners get your
very own american-made 1500 degree
infrared grill today at
schwankgrills.com all you need is promo
code mp at checkout to get 150 off your
purchase
again that's 150 off at
schweinkrills.com with code mp
shwinkgirls.com mp
andrew keane welcome to my podcast well
thank you so much michaela for inviting
me
before we get started can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
uh i'm a internet entrepreneur based in
san francisco california on the edge of
silicon valley
they have uh probably the the world's
most viewed daily podcast about books
and new writing called keen on
uh which you can find on the lithub
network i'm also the host of how to fix
democracy
uh which is uh my award-winning show and
movie about the future of democracy i've
written four books
uh and
numerous startups so i'll do lots of
different things
hey well you're on here to talk about
a.i the fear of ai
good well always happy to talk about ai
and i am the real andrew key and there's
no nothing artificial about me or you i
hope i'm michaela oh you never know
actually i have an artificial hip and an
artificial ankle but they're not
learning anything so okay
yeah
uh okay so what's your view on
ai is a positive is it a negative
i think you have to refine that question
a little bit more it's like me saying to
you uh michaela what's your view on the
internet or what's your view on life
it's too big a subject you need to
sharpen the question
okay i like you
if we have self-learning robots is it a
possibility that they're going to become
smarter than us and then view us as a
hindrance
i don't think it would be hard michaela
for robots to be smarter than us we're a
fairly dumb species
um whether we'll become the slaves of
them is a really interesting one i think
it's
a technological
issue which i quite frankly is kind of
beyond me i'm not a technologist the
idea it's an ongoing debate amongst
the hardcore scientists who study ai of
whether
um we can essentially
by giving uh
ai's giving robots giving smart machines
the ability to think whether they can
out think us and so i i
you know philosophically of course it's
a very sexy idea it's been the um
subject of many different science
fiction writers the idea of right from
the 19th century in fact even before the
19th century the idea of us creating
machines frankensteins which come to
rule us
uh so philosophically it's fascinating i
think it would be an appropriate end to
our species i think we
get what we deserve but uh in
technological terms i'm not quite sure i
just don't i don't understand that the
the
the increase the intricacies of the
debate in terms of
whether or not
we can build machines which then go on
to think for themselves and then think
beyond us if we do then we are the
footnote as somebody famously said they
are our last invention uh so it's it's
impossible to say and uh for me at least
and i think the scientific community is
very divided and when you talk to
serious scientists rather than
people who just seek headlines
most of them will say well we really
really don't know it it's such a
complicated subject and perhaps
a subject which will surprise us because
uh we'll only know when we know so as i
said you know maybe you're maybe you're
and i am maybe i'm an aon
[Music]
i only know when we know
maybe we'll never know and that will be
the
the interesting narrative that will get
ruled by ais and we won't even know it
maybe we already are
well that's a horrifying
well i don't know aren't you happy you
seem quite a cheerful person maybe it's
it wouldn't bother me in the world today
if ai's are ruling they're not doing a
bad job they could do a lot worse i'm
sure i don't know i just had to move
from canada i wasn't very happy by how
that was being run but maybe it needs
more ai oh you're where are you now i'm
in nashville tennessee so you went from
canada to nashville yeah isn't that
going from the
frying pan to the fire
oh it depends what you identify the fire
as uh okay
okay so
ai
it's it so it's in the military now
you know they're using smart machines to
track faces and everything and then each
side has their own ai
do you think
so it's already implemented in some
areas do you think when it gets
implemented in factories this is going
to be an issue for factory workers or
people who have more automated jobs
yeah that's an interesting question it's
already being implemented i mean it's
when people talk about new tech when
people talk about the internet when
people talk about the next generation
technology some people use the term now
web 3 as the next chapter after web 2.0
it's everywhere it's ubiquitous so
whenever you're talking about tech or
big tech or big tech companies you're
talking about ai so amazon for example
is essentially an ai company google is
an ai company facebook is a good ai
company even apple
uh
is an ai company focusing on hardware so
it's already in factories if you have
the
ill fortune of working in an amazon
factory you're being watched all the
time by smart machines
your ability or inability on the shop
floor is being watched and increasingly
they'll be technologies which are often
being championed by
tech investors like jeff bezos the
founder of amazon
technologies of surveillance which are
designed to make sure that we do our job
and to evaluate us and measure us so
i i don't think of that in futuristic
terms it's it's already arrived the
really interesting question is when it
begins to affect
uh
the higher end workers and i use that
term carefully i'm not sure we're so
high-end but whether it's commentators
like you or i
whether it's lawyers or doctors or
engineers or politicians
but we're in the midst of this
revolution and it's a very profound one
in terms of the workplace so for example
there's a big debate as you know about
whether or not people should go back to
the workplace and the office which is an
interesting debate and it doesn't affect
me because i've always worked from home
but a lot of people it does affect and
they think well they have more freedom
at home more independence but actually
they don't with all this new technology
observing people's work it doesn't mean
just a camera but it's smart tech which
can determine whether or not we're
actually working or
doing something else so all this
technology is designed to measure our
performance
in the workplace and perhaps elsewhere
and it's already arrived we're in the
midst of this revolution it's a very
profound one it's probably
the most profound one of the 21st
century so that's why um
you know this question of whether ai
rules is scientific and headline
grabbing but actually kind of
uninteresting the really interesting
question is
the tech of ai which is much more
mundane and down to earth but actually
changing the world as we speak
so
are you talking the tech are you
referring to things like ai that's able
to
answer
well that's different that's ai that's
used
for
medicine
so there's lots of ais that help
engineers and doctors and journalists i
mean there's ai
um for me as a writer i mean it's very
basic ai but it helps me spell
um
so that's a different issue what we're
talking about ai in the workplace it's
ai that evaluates our performance so it
goes the other way ai can be very useful
too i mean there's no doubt about that
no one would argue against ai that can
help fix cancer
but it goes both ways i mean the thing
with ai is it's so ubiquitous it's like
me saying
you know are you for or against oxygen
or are you for against the internet
clearly there are arguments for and
against but it's so ubiquitous and
essential that it's very easy to make
arguments for or against
do you think there's any way going
forward that the government or somebody
i don't know who could implement
policies to stop some of the negatives
people are concerned about about ai in
the workplace
yeah there will be but remember the
american government you're a canadian
immigrant um
the american government is profoundly
dysfunctional it has one of the least
effective governments in the world
staffed by
generally incompetent people because
smart americans don't go into government
it's badly paid and frowned upon in our
in our social
hierarchies and culture
so the american government won't be the
government that addresses this in the
same way as the american government
hasn't been the government that
addresses
the dangers of big tech companies this
will likely be done in two ways by two
kinds of government
by the
sort of
authoritarian technocracy in china
where
they will just announce
regulation and legislation of
according to sort of some wise man
precept
chinese culture
which has been inherited now by the
chinese communist party
and then by the the democracies of
northern europe the german government
the scandinavian government and the eu
government which i think will do a
reasonably good job uh american
government is always second or third in
this so eventually as these threats are
regulated and legislated against
so the american government will will
pick it up
they've done that with big tech they're
only beginning to address the dangers of
big tech now after the europeans and the
chinese have addressed it
what what did the chinese do to address
the dangers of big tech
well they shut them down they find them
they put their leaders in jail i'm not
saying it's necessarily a good thing but
that's one effective way of doing it
chinese have a very strong effective
functional government
whereas the americans don't which is why
the chinese economy is stronger it's why
chinese society is more
perhaps successful i wouldn't i would
prefer i think personally to live in the
united states but certainly china is a
more successful society than the united
states
richer
happier people less crime less prisons
all the indicators all the indexes which
indicate happiness
and success
is there less poverty there
much less than in the united states was
the last time you're in san francisco
michaela it's become a giant homeless
camp yeah i was just in new york
yesterday it's becoming like san
francisco
awful toronto was like that that's why i
moved yeah not as bad as new york but
getting there right well how's nashville
amazing
yeah no homeless no poverty not really i
mean there are there are areas like any
you know american city but
compared to toronto it's much better
people are
happier
good i have to come and visit
yeah you should it's pretty nice down
here
right in the middle of america
uh okay
what about the fact so i want to go back
to china for a sec
there's an issue with the fact that
government has as much power over
citizens
don't you think ai implemented at a
government level surveilling everybody
isn't that an issue collecting all the
data
oh it's definitely an issue i mean i've
written and spoken about this a lot the
chinese are refining what i would call a
digital orwellian
state
um
or well of course in 1980 in 1948 wrote
a book called 1984 which was a warning
about
i guess an analog surveillance state
a sort of stalinist analog surveillance
state which he thought was coming into
being after the second world war when
stalinism was the dominant form of
government in in in eastern europe and
in the soviet union and
imminently in china
what the chinese are doing are refining
a kind of
techno-capitalist surveillance state
where everyone is watched all the time
and where the government is controlling
the levers
the technologies of surveillance
yeah it's terrifying i don't want to
live there but it but it's effective
whereas in contrast the american
government is
um
profoundly dysfunctional and is
resulting in a society that's failing
uh which as another subject your your
fellow countryman stephen marsh
uh i'm interviewing him next month on my
known show he has a new book out about
the imminence of civil war in america
there's going to be a whole rash and i
use that word carefully of books
in the early 2022 about
civil war in america the breakdown of
government i mean the government's kind
of already broken down but that's not
justifying the chinese system it's not
either or there are alternatives
um and as i said the european model
of a stronger more functional state with
politicians and regulators who are
respected that's probably
the best compromise between
chinese
techno-authoritarianism and american
dysfunctional government
don't don't areas of europe have an
immigration problem that's potentially
destroying parts of it though
you mean um
americans coming over
no i meant places like paris and from
north africa coming over specifically
what's going to do with the government
i mean immigration policy wouldn't that
be the government
yeah i mean that's another question i
don't think that has anything to do with
surveillance culture or the
effectiveness of government um and uh i
i don't think that um
you know i think they're different parts
of the world so
the issue of immigration in europe and
in in north america is different but
yeah i don't think that's got anything
to do with it
i don't think it has anything to do with
surveillance but i was commenting on how
effective the government was for
building a society
yeah but
the european model still works and it's
still trying to be emulated around the
world whereas the american north america
the united states one isn't america is a
joke around the world the american
the dysfunctionality of american society
and government now is is perhaps the
dominant theme of early 21st century
the global world that
laughed at around the world because
system doesn't work and the country is
on the brink of civil war
uh
that's a different issue from having an
immigration policy problem which of
course it does have
you said you've written books on how to
fix democracy
i've made a film about how to fix
democracy
and so do you have a solution for
america that can avoid civil disaster
no
i think america is beyond hope actually
i'm afraid it's uh i'm about to do an
interview on my show with eric topper
you know the leading one of america's
leading doctors and i think america is
the equivalent of that corpse or almost
corpse
that's about to die and there's not much
you can do about it i'm afraid
well do you have a plan are you going to
stay here and watch the collapse are you
moving
no it doesn't bother
uh
coastal elites like myself
we fly in and out doesn't mean different
it's not gonna be full civil war
full-scale civil war like in the 19th
century
it will
be outbreak i mean it's already kind of
i mean this is a
this is separate from a.i but
it will be a low-level kind of civil war
that sort of lebanese style or
it's not gonna i don't think it will be
like syria
but basically government breakdown sort
of eruptions of violence around the
country it's not going to affect
new york or san francisco or los angeles
but it still will result in the
breakdown ultimately of of order it's
this book by stephen marsh is really
good he he does an excellent job i read
it a couple of weeks ago it's out in
early january should get him on your
show
even marsh i'm writing that down
m-a-r-c-h-e
okay
that's
fascinating
you're a very interesting character i'm
kind of upset i brought you on to talk
about ai
why
well i don't know we could be talking
about the crash of civilizations that's
something where we are
we are maybe i'm an ai designed to upset
you
ai's part of it all as well you know ai
is um
there's a piece of the narrative it's a
chapter in the breakdown
relying on machines which don't do a
very good job generally
yeah i know
i had to talk to one on a phone
yesterday too you did a credit card oh
yeah it was awful
yeah yeah i always put the phone down
whenever you talk to if
i think we all have to
uh agree that whenever you're talking to
an af we put the phone down enough times
eventually their masters and they remain
humans will um
will get the message and put real people
on
yeah press zero enough times that
sometimes works although if you you
never know me kayla if you do it enough
times you may get one of those
immigrants from europe one of those
north africans who you don't like
they'll be on the phone with you they'll
know who you are they'll be calling you
all the time
i don't know if muhammad from tangiers
will be on to michaela
i still think that there's an
immigration policy problem when
something another show have me back on
we can have a serious chat about that
okay
okay i will for sure
so do you
so the guy i talked to who was more you
know this is going to happen ai is going
to become a thing but i'm not saying it
isn't i've said it's going to happen
it's inevitable but do you think they're
actually going to be able to make
machines that can out-think humans
well you asked me that before
i i think
you got to rephrase the question because
from a technological point of view i'm
not able to answer that so maybe if you
rephrase it would i would i like
to have machines that come out think
humans maybe ask me that
okay would you like to have machines
that can out thank humans
i i shouldn't say this but i but since
you have a pretty big audience i'm not
sure if anyone's going to be watching
this as soon as they see me they'll
probably switch off but um
i would like to have machines that i
think humans i think we had such a
pathetic species that it would actually
be amusing
i'm not sure how we'd react maybe would
get us to grow up and think a bit more
responsibly but i don't think it would
necessarily be a bad thing it'd be
interesting i mean maybe they'd be wiser
more humane who knows
i mean the idea of the
kind of the hardcore ai community is we
could fill these algorithms
with our best qualities so we could make
them human we could make them
sympathetic
we could make them smart
and
i guess that's
possible the problem
is whenever you hear those arguments and
and maybe there's some truth in them
they're always going to be owned by
humans
so it's like the google argument or the
facebook argument oh we're going to make
the world a better place we're going to
liberate we're going to democratize
we're going to decentralize
we're going to empower
and all those things may be true of
social media and ubiquitous search and
amazon but ultimately these products and
services and platforms have human
masters
so the problem with making an ai that's
smarter than us
more sympathetic more responsible wiser
is it will still have human masters who
will profit economically politically
culturally
so that's the really scary thing about
dominant ais you have it in silicon
valley you have this it was
you know i've been i've been living here
since for the last 30 or 40 years and
i've seen it
time after time after time technology is
saying oh now we have the fix now we
have the solution
now we have technology that will
essentially make us better that will
take our best bits
and liberate us from our bad bits
and sometimes that's true we've seen it
with social media
we heard all the arguments oh well
big media's bad is controlled by these
people no one has a voice so we gave
everyone a voice we gave them a platform
we even made it free
and look what's happening we've had the
destruction of democracy we've had
basically online civil war the breakdown
of civility
and the biggest problem
of all is there is a young man and he
remains a young man who owns this ai his
name's mark zuckerberg and he's made
tens hundreds of billions of dollars off
this ai the same is true of google and
amazon and facebook and all the rest of
these companies so the real problem with
ai is not the ai itself it's who owns it
yeah
so so the the vision that some people
have which i don't believe i don't know
how it works is to have an open source
platform you know
a bitcoin blockchain style ai that's
owned by everyone collectively but those
things never work ultimately
it's like those free credit card offers
or those people who are calling you when
you when you talk to your credit card
companies
the promise and the reality are entirely
different
so whenever there's a promise of
everything's free and everything's
perfect and we're in control i'm always
deeply suspicious i was suspicious 20
years ago about web 2.0 and i was proved
right was one of the first people to
raise a warning about
uh
social media and web 2.0 and i think
that's the same is true of ai the same
is true of bitcoin and blockchain when
you listen to these promises oh well
we're going to liberate currency from
the central banks everyone will earn
currency there'll be no
no more money it will be a p2p economic
system the truth is they're still
speculators and owners of these products
and the same will be true of ai and i
don't see any way that ai can really
become a public good unless
it's controlled by government and then
we come back to our earlier conversation
we have the
the the truly
dystopian chinese model where the
government owns ai and controls it for
its own benefit
or we have a the american model where
government is just dysfunctional nothing
happens so everything is controlled by
private companies
or we have in a european model that
tries to mix the two and have a an
authoritative government which still
acts in a responsible democratic way so
that's the challenge you have all these
new ai platforms um
and they're all promising some sort of
openness whenever when anyone michaela
comes on your show and uses the o word
open be suspicious
because nothing is ever truly open
there's always someone owning it behind
it so
the open word the o word uh open is
always really about ownership and we
can't and my fear with ai is we're never
gonna get beyond ownership there will
always be someone who owns it
there'll always be some smart human
maybe a james bond evil character
a zuckerberg style character jeff bezos
and elon musk who own this stuff and are
getting enormously rich off it and
enormously powerful and that's
from my point of view
it's chilling particularly
when they articulate the double speak of
silicon valley and promise
to make the world a better place but in
truth they're only making the world a
better place for themselves and their
investors and workers
okay i think we're pretty much in
agreement mike my concern we are i
didn't come on to agree with you well
what about those muslims those dangerous
muslims
on the border you said we have to do
that in another podcast okay we'll do
that another one we should um i think my
concern with ai would be somebody
controlling it who thinks that they're
doing something good for the world and
really truly believes that they aren't
because you don't have evil people you
don't have i don't think you really have
evil people i think you have people who
think they're doing good and then do
evil which is yeah that was a warrior
yeah there was a wonderful book one of
perhaps the most profound 20th century
american thinker on tech and
big tech companies was a man who taught
at new york university called um neil
postman and in 1984
which of course was the year that all
well predicted in his 1984 would come
into being uh postman wrote a book
called amusing ourselves to death
and in that introduction it's a
wonderful introduction about four or
five pages he says we all got it wrong
the real danger in 1984 wasn't or was
1984
it was brave new world it was aldous
huxley's dystopia
of a a techno authoritarianism and i
think he's right and i think the book
uh for your viewers um
if you want to
really worry about the future don't read
1984 read brave new world uh
huxleys i think it was 1934 warning
about a world saturated with technology
a world in which government uses
technology to make everyone happy
yeah i read that in high school that was
a scary book
too much pleasure right
too much pleasure and then the force of
no pain it's a it's a dystopian
utilitarianism
and of course um it's one in which
everyone is intoxicated a government
which gives out pills to make people
forget
um and and i'm afraid you know that's
what social media is and that's what
that's the world we're living in it's
very different from say the chinese
model
china isn't doing that i mean china is
kind of mixed the chinese
digital totalitarian system is a mix of
orwell and huxy because if the leader of
china
maybe like it you read in high school
both brave new world in 1984 and said
well i don't want i'm gonna get them
both and that's what they're doing in
china
do you think that kind of system is
going to outlast the us
yeah it's a much more successful system
if you're
if you're
a government
leader or um wannabe politician in
central or latin america in africa in in
most of south asia and you think
okay well which model are we gonna
choose are we gonna choose the
dysfunctionality of america on the brink
of civil war for city like san francisco
which is dominated by homeless people or
the chinese model that works it may not
be very pleasant may not be very moral
but it works i've done a lot of speeches
around the world on tech and i was at
the u.n
just before kobe doing a speech to the
the assembly there on the dangers of web
2.0
uh and the dangers of big tech in
america and the the the the people who
were most sympathetic what i was saying
were many of the delegates from africa
you know back in the the old cold war
cold war 1.0 in the late you know in the
late 19th 20th century
the the western model work no one wanted
to go and live in the soviet union it
was dysfunctional it was dark it didn't
work everyone lived in poverty
everything was unpleasant but the
chinese model is a much more effective
model than the us model so that's the
challenge is we got to come up
with a model that can compete with china
which isn't as
autocratic isn't as evil isn't as
unpleasant
and is it going to be the business
owners who do that considering the
government's dysfunctional
it may be the business
donors
you know i've had a lot of people on my
show talking about social capitalism it
may be reforming democracy itself
citizen assemblies reforming government
one of the biggest problems in america
is just the the political system is
archaic
it's built on an 18th century
rural country that no longer exists so
we need profound reform maybe we need to
unleash the citizen
um they're doing that again in europe
they're doing it with citizen assemblies
they're doing it in canada they're not
doing it in the united states so
america for all its
um
forward-ness
and innovation when it comes to tech
is profoundly reactionary and
conservative when it comes to any kind
of institutional or constitutional
reform
okay well
i'd love to keep talking to you i don't
want to keep you on because i know you
have something to do
yeah well lovely talking to me kayla and
we'll have to come on again and talk
about those
immigrants in europe i would really
enjoy that uh if if people want to find
you
if they don't you want to find me um i'm
everywhere uh and nowhere like hey i you
know you i'm aj keane on twitter
uh uh follow uh follow my keen on show
it's um
uh it's of course you can find it
anywhere on apple it's on lithub it's
the one of the the the featured shows on
on lithub.com i have a sub stack page
called keen on
uh i'm not on facebook because i don't
like facebook uh i'm on linkedin so i'm
easy to find them aj keen.com on the web
so it's a real pleasure i enjoyed this
conversation michaela and thank you so
much
thank you very much for coming on this
episode was brought to you by nordvpn
have you ever worried about things like
is my data secure when on public wi-fi
or what if somebody steals my identity
don't be that person that would be a
neurotic person i'm certainly not but i
may be so unconcerned i go too far in
the wrong direction to get the best
protection against cyber crime nordvpn's
new threat protection feature blocks
trackers ads and malware lurking online
it's a brand new feature of nordvpn and
comes absolutely free
most people know about nordvpn i
probably don't have to tell you guys
it's the fastest vpn on the planet
did you know it's the safest as well
nordvpn uses the same encryption
standard as top secret nsa files and
they have a strict no log policy on your
data which is why they're headquartered
in panama it's a panama law thing
apparently but most importantly nordvpn
can be used to bypass countries and
companies that are stopping you from
accessing videos and content online like
serbia blocking disney hotels blocking
certain youtube videos in canada
blocking anything remotely good on
netflix grab your exclusive nordvpn deal
by going to nordvpn.com
tmpp
to get a huge discount off your nordvpn
plan plus
free threat protection plus one
additional month for free it's
completely risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee that's at
nordvpn.com
tmpp
i hope you enjoy
the rest of this episode
[Music]
steven umbrella welcome to my podcast
thank you for having me
before we get started can you give my
audience a
brief intro about who you are and what
you do
sure
i'm the right now the managing director
for the institute for ethics and
emerging technologies which is a 501c3
nonprofit think tank out of boston
and our general aim is to promote ideas
about how technological progress can
increase freedom happiness
and human flourishing in democratic
societies and i'm also a research fellow
at the delft university of technology
where right now i'm working on creating
stakeholder meetings
for technologies like geoengineering
neurotechnologies and digital extended
reality and wow aside from yeah that
academic stuff i'm
the editor of uh the robot the ethics
and robotics series with tribe and
publishing
where my forthcoming book design for
death will be coming out soon
designed for death
okay
that sounds intriguing so
you're of the opinion that a.i isn't
going to take over the world and then
destroy us eventually no absolutely not
but why is that
well first of all we have to
i think we're a lot of source where a
lot of confusion comes from in both the
academic and particularly in public
conversations on ai is well what is ai
exactly because it's yeah kind of like a
buzz word right now that everyone likes
to use
uh and the issues is that there's no
agreed-upon definition of actually what
ai is like globally so i'd argue if i
were to give a definition
that it would be best understood as a
class of technologies
that are autonomous they're interactive
so we can interact with them they're
adaptive so they can learn to new
situations uh new challenges in their
environments and they're capable of
carrying out human-like tasks and in
particular when we use the word ai and
that definition it's mostly those
technologies which are based on machine
learning
which allows the system to learn on the
basis of their interaction with and
feedback from their environment so i
would say that that would probably be
the simplest way of understanding what
ai
systems are but there's actually the
european commission actually recently
came out with
uh and they're well aware of this issue
a draft legislation for artificial
intelligence and it's for promoting
uptake of ai
and addressing the risks associated with
the new technology and they actually
came up with a pretty good
definition of ai and that's probably
what would be the benchmark from now on
of what ai is what i want to start with
i think is
if ai continues to be implemented is it
going to end up taking jobs away from
people who do kind of not to call it
menial tasks but repetitive tasks and is
that going to be an issue
yeah i think this will undoubtedly be
the case and we've already seen how the
various industrial revolutions
from mechanization and electricity to
telecommunications electronics and more
recently obviously big data ai in the
internet and these revolutions naturally
come with huge shifts in labor and
production
uh we can think back to the english
textile workers of the 19th century that
destroyed their machinery in particular
the cotton and wool mills
that they believed were threatening
their jobs and these people are called
the luddites and now we use that term to
refer to someone who's opposed to
new technologies and associated ways of
working with those technologies that are
substitutive and the iat where i work is
actually doing a lot of research on this
particular topic and in actually in
collaboration with the university of
massachusetts boston the iat hired
actually its first postdoctoral fellow
in the future of work to explore
questions surrounding technological
unemployment which is essentially the
question that you just asked and how to
address it and looking at questions like
if automation is liberating us from the
drudgery or just exacerbating
inequalities and i think the next few
years of this research going to be
pretty interesting so anybody who's
interested in that should just keep an
eye out on the work we're doing because
we'll publish it
interesting okay
i suppose the argument might be that if
some of those jobs go away humanity will
adapt
right in some way that maybe we can't
even
imagine at the moment
the the not imaginary moment perhaps um
i think that that comes with uh
an underlying presumption that
um ai
needs to substitute now of course it
will substitute a certain degree because
we've already seen that in uh in the
other industrial revolutions how that's
changed and you know there's some jobs
that simply do not exist anymore and
unfortunately that means there's certain
jobs that may not exist anymore in going
into the future and that's going to be a
serious question that we don't really
have a solid answer to us what are we
going to do with the people that are
going to be displaced because there will
be a certain portion of the population
that will be displaced hmm
okay well i guess we'll see what happens
do you when do you think that's going
that kind of thing is going to happen i
mean it's already happening but is there
going to be a period in the next 10
years when that's going to pose a
significant problem
i don't think it'll pose a significant
problem if we readjust the way that we
we look at ai so if we have this uh
active attempt at creating artificial
intelligence systems with the purpose
of substituting humans rather than
trying to empower people
uh rather than try to augment uh what
they're already capable of so these are
systems that work alongside humans in
order to increase their capabilities
then perhaps we will increasingly face
the issue of technological unemployment
but if we shift if we have a paradigm
shift in the way we actually look at a.i
and understand it as being um
supplementary to human labor in order to
increase our productivity and all and
also perhaps our well-being then perhaps
we won't face as much of that particular
uh that particular element of ai
substituting people of technological
unemployment
yeah i guess that would have to be
implemented at the government level
probably otherwise corporations are
going to be like nah we don't need
workers i'll just buy this program we'll
do everything we see that already don't
we to a certain degree
yeah definitely
cool
it sounds like a fun job kind of very
interesting
uh do you think there's there are issues
with uh artificial intelligence
impacting privacy and data
oh wow
uh
i would say that we can rephrase that
for a little bit and say uh
what do we do about the privacy issues
that we
have now given in terms of how
governments control ai systems and
systems more broadly because there's
already issues that perhaps that will be
exacerbated i think they will be but
there's already issues with uh
governments controlling ai systems so
you know china is the classic example
and naturally the corporate media is
more than willing to saber rattle and
push the narrative despite the fact that
the chinese state does employ these
methods still it shouldn't dis distract
us the the very real example of china
and what they're doing from what's
actually going on right now on the home
front i'm not sure if you've heard but
back in 2019 uh the organization called
epic which is the electronic electronic
privacy information center uh filed
strangely enough successfully a freedom
of information requests to the us
government and they got a bunch of
documents back revealing how the
national security commission on ai which
is well a relatively
little known body i never heard of it
before this uh which was created uh with
the 2018 ndaa the national defense
authorization act
and
these documents revealed how
artificial intelligence can address and
this is quote
the national security and defense needs
of the united states and it discusses
even further the structural changes
that need to be made in both american
economy and society to ensure that the
us maintains a technological advantage
over china so you know what is that
supposed to mean yeah exactly
you go okay that makes sense given what
china is doing wanna you know stay on
top and that's what america does but the
document is actually pretty scary in
terms of the suggestions that are made
they argue that the u.s should adopt the
china-style mass surveillance program in
order to lead or even surpass china
concerning ai-driven technologies like
facial recognition and citizen scoring
which is actually what's prohibited in
that european regulation that i
mentioned before that type of technology
and funny although unsurprising the that
u.s body responsible for these proposals
that was gone through this uh foia uh is
chaired by the former head of google
eric schmidt where it further goes this
is crazy
yeah and it further goes into how the
regula this is what the document says
that the regulatory barriers
need to be removed on emerging ai
technologies and it even goes so far as
to boldly say that existing privacy laws
need to be changed so that the us
government can do all of that what i
just said more openly whereas up until
now they've been doing it secretly to
citizens
wow
that's crazy
welcome to the dystopian nightmare that
people have been talking about for years
now
oh my gosh okay what do you think is
gonna happen like how much power does
that tiny
what would you what would you refer to
that
not bored what did you call it what was
the acronym
yeah
that that government body the nation the
national security commission on ai
okay
and
so is that actually gonna happen like is
that already happening
if what edward snowden revealed is any
indication of what's been going up and
on until now it seems that's exactly
what will probably happen
we're already seeing the kind of
infrastructure being put into place that
allows for this i saw
someone from uh one of the central banks
in canada discussing digital id
uh and you know saying how secure it is
nothing is fully secure but it allows
the government to close your bank
accounts we we see what the tyrant in
canada has already done to certain
citizens in their bank account so
i i think the president has already been
sent
oh my gosh well this was more dramatic
than i thought it was going to be
so is there any i mean i guess i can
understand if
not that i agree with it but i can
understand if the government is
concerned about china just overtaking
and they're like wow we'll just do it
but better which
is not
it's almost like can't beat them join
them but they're still trying to beat
them to a certain degree and it's by
going even further
what okay
what do we do about this is there
anything and how can you be on the pro
ai side here
ai does have a bunch of benefits when
it's designed for human values and not
for the tech the technocracy and the
oligarchs who are you know trying to
control everything or sorry
mostly do control everything
what can be done about that right now
well first of all i think most people
need to know what's going on and i think
to a certain degree people like yourself
who spread these kinds of messages or
allow people to discuss these things for
example i would suggest that people who
are interested in this particular uh
issue right here what's going on in the
united states uh they should check out
uh the great journalism being done by
whitney webb who's taken a lot of care
to documents like this and these issues
she's watching the watchers essentially
despite the risks that come with this
kind of journalism she's definitely an
excellent resource
okay wow that's terrifying okay so we're
we're basically screwed then though
aren't we i mean because it's not going
to be designed to help people
that's not what's going to happen what
do you think
not the systems that they're discussing
no not unless there's
uh
real
populist resistance against these things
but you cannot have that resistance
unless people know about it
wow george orwell will be rolling in his
grave if you heard this because this is
something
beyond 1984.
wow
that's terrifying okay
okay so how could let's go into more
positive direction for now although
we'll probably go back to that because
that's kind of fun but
how could ai be designed going forward
so that
it doesn't end up just destroying
everyone's privacy and we don't turn
into china
okay well that that's actually like two
different uh particulars because there's
what's already being done at the
government level in harnessing the power
of ai and then there's more of that the
design level in how can we design safe
reliable and trustworthy and these
separate slightly separate domains if
you're asking me about the former of
what do we do about what the government
wants to do well i think that that's at
uh more
at a national level what do the people
want right and like i mentioned they
have to know about what's going on
before they can actually say what they
want so these things are currently not
transparent i'm actually surprised that
the foia request was granted i think
that's almost crazy but then again it
does state that they want to do this
openly so it's not even one it's not a
secret anymore nor is it a conspiracy
when we have the foia documents you know
they're published online and it even
says within them they want to do a
publicly but if we go to the design side
i think there are ways of designing safe
reliable and trustworthy ai and i'll
give you just like a few examples if you
want
um
so there's this um
there's something called z inspection
and it's a process that has the
potential i think to play a key role uh
in the context of the new european
union's ai regulation that i mentioned
and essentially it's an initiative of a
team of
international independent researchers
and i work with them
which takes real-life case studies of ai
such as certain ai systems in the
healthcare domain and they apply this
process
as a way of achieving trustworthy ai and
it's a general inspection process so we
look at something that already exists an
ai system that already exists and we
look at
how can we apply ethical ai to them in a
variety of domains like business
healthcare public sectors and we use the
definition of trustworthy ai that's
given by the high-level uh european
commission's expert group on ai but we
actually even go beyond
the key elements that the european union
asks for and we provide an additional
two more one of them is assessing if the
ecosystems respect the values of western
european democracy and whether we can
avoid a concentration of power that's
what we just discussed the concentration
of power here
so for example we took a close look at a
deep learning based skin lesion
classifier to see how we can use the
process to code design in such a way as
to make it trustworthy so the system
explains decisions made by deep learning
networks analyzing images of skin
lesions and this is an example of what
we call computer-aided diagnostic
systems or cad systems
and they've
they've been shown to yield higher
sensitivity and specificity in
diagnosing uh malignant melanoma by
analyzing uh dermatoscopic pictures
compared to well-trained dermatologists
so they actually show efficacy and
beyond yeah but
and this is usually the the cause of
hesitancy when employing these type of
ai systems like this is the acceptance
of these cad systems in real clinical
setups is actually quite limited so it
hasn't been uptaken at large scales and
that's because their decision making
processes how it actually makes
decisions
are
more often than not largely obscure and
that's because there's a lack of
explainability it's what we call black
box we don't know what's going inside
the black box
yeah but you know we argue that in order
for
to in order to code design trustworthy
ai with a holistic approach means that
we need some unique access uh aspects in
the structure and the design process
or more specifically we need an
interdisciplinary team of experts coming
from the domain of the ai application so
in this case with the cad system that
would be the field of health care
as well as other fields like the
technical side the legal side the social
and ethical side so we need an
interdisciplinary team working together
to uncover what the issues are and then
working with the design team in order to
address these issues so it's a
collaborative co-constructed effort and
that's just one of the many frameworks
that has been proposed for actually
achieving reliable safe and trustworthy
ai
okay so that makes sense
that's interesting
yeah so ai can be used in medical set us
medical settings much more effectively
right because they probably have better
pattern recognition they can just
contain more data than people
yeah so ai systems in healthcare
definitely can be used to assist
healthcare workers in their you know
day-to-day work what you would consider
perhaps to be slight drudgery right or
routine things and ideally it could be
leveraged to enhance preventative care
and quality of life as well as produce
more accurate diagnoses and treatment
plans
but recently there's been issues
regarding this the proper design of
systems could significantly increase the
quality of medical care so for example
back in 2017 there was actually a study
in the journal
of the american medical association
where an ai model was able to accurately
diagnose breast cancer at a higher rate
than 11 top pathologists
so
it definitely is possible
great that's good significant benefits
yeah yeah
yeah okay so
is that
why hasn't that been put in you said
this you talked about it a little bit
but why hasn't that been put in the
medical system
is it just slow
unfortunately there has been
um
some pushback from the the medical field
given their
the general hesitancy
of ai systems more broadly and although
it is true that medical
um although it's true that
ai systems particularly within popular
media have shown to be
less than uh accurate in certain
circumstances
uh certain medical experts are you know
less than happy to fully trust the
system and when when you don't when you
ask the system or when you look at the
system when a medical expert like a
doctor goes okay it showed me that
there's this malignant melanoma i want
to know why
why the system told me this
particularly if it's not 100 accurate
we're never going to get that 100
actually we want progress not perfection
so
there's always going to be a certain
amount of doubt and one there is a
amount of doubt which is fine and you
can't figure out why the system made the
decision that did the black box then
you're far less likely to actually trust
the system
okay
that makes sense
do you view the human brain as something
that can be replicated with ai
so
replicated fully no because it depends
exactly what you mean uh our brain is
wet wear but if we're talking in
silicone not exactly so
what you're perhaps asking is about deep
learning
and deep learning is actually a further
subfield of machine learning and it's
usually understood and inspired by how
the human brain functions
and uses what is often referred to as
artificial neural networks so you know
in order to simulate how our brain works
but in silicone so essentially it works
by
learning from examples in a similar way
that actually humans learn new things
they're actually yeah they're actually
pretty good uh systems and they work
great at classifying images actually
quite accurately in text and sounds and
they can even perform at levels better
than humans can at doing that test so
you know one of their main benefits like
machine learning more broadly because
deep learning is a type of machine
learning
is that these systems are capable of
computing huge vast quantities of data
that would be impossible to compute with
traditional methods in a coherent way
and more traditional techniques and
machine learning are pretty linear
whereas deep learning neural networks
are stacked in hierarchies of different
levels of abstraction so imagine we want
to teach like a deep learning system
what a car is
well how does a kid like a child learn
what a car is and what a car is not
because that's also part of what
learning what a car is what it isn't
while the child can you know point at
the car and say that's a car and then
the parent can either say yes that's a
car no that's not a car and as a child
continues to point at different
cars
they're able to abstract from all those
experiences the features of what a car
isn't and what a and what a car is and i
guess you say that's kind of like the
platonic carness
in essence that they're that they're
okay
yeah
deep certain deep learning systems work
work in this way
very similar to the way we would learn
or we tried to mimic that in silicone
okay
and
do you see that
progressing to the point where it's
comparable to a human
no
i i have a hard time with uh the concept
of ai
uh being anthropomorphized too far
uh the classic terminator you know yeah
a threat to humanity right taking over
we see the images all the time on
magazines and movies i love those movies
great
uh but i have a really hard time
uh with with that particular way of
conceiving
of uh of ai and if you want to tell you
why yeah yeah i do want to know why well
you know if we take that that definition
of ai that i gave at the beginning as as
our starting point it's hard to imagine
that the thing
that that type of thing is taking over
anything or being a significant global
threat and usually the discussions of ai
as being as a threat to humanity or you
know on an existential level is
referring to speculative artificial
general intelligence or artificial super
intelligence something out of hollywood
and nick bostrom actually a professor at
the university of oxford and his book
called super intelligence talked about
this
but despite you know the popular media
having their fun with with this it's not
a really realistic picture of what ai is
it's just not
it puts the wrong idea of what ai is in
people's minds and this kind of embodied
mechanistic god that can do anything
because it's more intelligent than us
but we're so far removed from that kind
of scenario that talking about it
amounts to nothing more than having fun
and i i think it's actually worse than
that talking about ai like that does
more harm than good
like for one there's the risk that the
public will see these futuristic ideas
of ai whether good or bad and create
pretty big expectations in their minds
about what i ai is and what it can do
and this is actually pretty bad for ai
research because it can lead to another
what would be the third ai winter
and these are freezes in serious ai
research and development
hence the winter part and the freezes
that come as a consequence of overly
ambitious promises that ai can yield
with the actual results being pretty
humbler than expectations and this
happened in the mid 70s and in the late
80s early 90s and it's the perceptual
loss and faith of what ai can do that
leads to the actual loss in funding uh
to do this research and you know we're
living in kind of like this renaissance
of sorts where everything is ai which is
of course nonsense but what it does
reveal is that there's you know
pretty big global interest in the
capabilities that ai can offer us still
you think we you know learn our lesson
by now but these kinds of exaggerated
illustrations of ai in popular
culture can eventually blow up uh in our
faces and there's also another danger
and worrying about the risks of
artificial general or artificial super
intelligence
leads us to be distracted from the
actual issues that ai systems pose
and the most common of course is bias in
these systems and bias can exist across
all levels in all stages of how an ai
system is conceived trained built and
used
so we have to address these concerns
head on if we want to build ai for
social good ai for people rather than
have you know to constantly rate
headlines about how ai
systems reinforce discrimination or
existing spheres of disproportionate
influence and power
okay well i feel somewhat better
with that answer i can get rid of the
arnold schwarzenegger taking over the
world type robot that's good but the
real problem is people who get their
hands on this and then
everything's destroyed because of what
they do with it which is equally as
scary
yeah it's that dual use of technology
not everyone uses a technology the way
the designers originally intended
yeah like like i thought about the
government that i mentioned
yeah we're going to get back into that
because i want to talk about exactly
what china is doing
but before we do that um what what did
you mean by built-in bias can you give
some examples of what that could look
like
sure yeah definitely so um let's take
the mortgage
industry for example so you know
obviously how an ai functions in the
real world is a consequence of well the
people who made it the designers it's
creators so there's actually numerous
examples of how a flawed algorithm leads
to well faulty outputs right if it's
faulty from the beginning it's going to
be faulty you know when it's actually
being used so when the designers create
software programs these programs are
constrained within specific parameters
and it's the nature of those parameters
to be the subject of interpretation so
for example if someone from a low-income
neighborhood submitted a mortgage
proposal there's good chance that that
proposal would be classified by the
system as high risk
and as a consequence the system will
recommend a high interest rate in order
to account for that risk that the firm
is going to have to shoulder
and the unfortunate thing is
that these neighbor how these
neighborhoods are divided are actually
has little to do with how income is
generated and more about the social
economic factor so you know things like
race for example and these systems
aren't capable of recognizing this bias
it can only account for and compute the
information based on its design
and this usually ends with you know a
firm's agent lacking proper
justification when they have to reject
the client and this is the black box
again why was i rejected i don't know
and you know this can lead to what i
would say is deleterious
uh impacts on the firm's reputation
given that people can quickly spread the
word of how they were rejected but they
weren't given a clear reason as to why
um
yeah that wouldn't be good if you want
to see some great bias and facial
recognition uh that's also a fun one
there's a whole host of examples so like
a few years ago in new jersey there was
a man that was arrested by police and
actually spent time in jail when they
followed what they called a high profile
comparison from
a facial recognition scan that they
extracted from a fake id that they found
at the crime scene
and the machine learning algorithm
that they used in the facial recognition
system learn to identify a person based
on their facial features
and these programs have been shown in a
number of studies to be less than
reliable to say the least and they're
certainly less than accurate in their
ability to properly identify
particularly black and asian faces
i remember there was one where google
want to google facial uh image
classifier classified uh black males as
gorillas in the same category
oh my gosh
yeah that is not what we want no
definitely not
okay so could that go
i want to get back into china what
china's doing
but could we end up with
ai systems that
are completely you know the population
is completely entrenched in this and
then you end up getting these kind of
mistakes where you identify people
improperly and then that ends up ruining
lives because ai has said oh no you know
with 99.9 certainty this is the guy you
want
and then that's it
life over
this is uh the classic example you
essentially just defined what we call
the colin ridge dilemma which is
we can't understand the full impacts of
a technology until it's ubiquitous and
therefore pervasive so it becomes kind
of like part of the social technical
infrastructure around us so it's like
normalized
but
once those things emerge it's so
entrenched that how do we actually go
back because it's so fundamental because
technologies don't come from nothing
right they build on previous iterations
and then they slowly become normalized
as they become diffused in society so
that's one of the reasons why we have to
adopt a design approach from the get-go
that does at least two things
so one of them is that we have to design
technologies for human values and that
means we have to enroll as many
stakeholders as possible that's not only
the designer who goes i'm going to build
this system and you know the ceo goes
trying to make profits those are
important stakeholders those are direct
stakeholders we also have to bring the
publics in because in the end the public
is going to be the users the environment
whatever it may be are going to be the
ones that are fundamentally impacted by
these technologies so they have to also
be part of the design program itself in
designing these technologies what are
their values how can we design for them
rather than sidelining them or as an
after fact
and i think that's gener that's good a
good rule for most technologies if not
all but ai we have to add something even
further is
a good way to conceptualize how to
design ai for social good is to get away
from this idea that ai is simply a
product you know a designer
makes something then they sell it and
then like they kind of just wash their
hands of it like no more of that is we
have to build in full life cycle
monitoring so because many of these
technologies are black box we don't know
why they do what they do in many cases
even if they could be trustworthy that
means that when we throw them out in the
world
they're most more likely than not to
display emerging behaviors that were
unforeseen or even unforeseeable
and if some of those
behaviors that are unforeseen or
unforeseeable aren't ones that we like
we need a way to one recognize them and
to have the mechanisms to kind of
rain things in to pull them back into
the design space to do another iteration
of design a firmware update or you know
a software update whatever it may be
it's no more let's build this let's sell
it and we're done that's not going to
work anymore given that these are
technologies that really do change over
time
i'm less confident about humanity's
ability to do this than i was at the
beginning of this conversation just so
you know
okay let's uh let's get back to
china i've got i've got a couple of
questions but one if the us
doesn't do this kind of competitive
thing they're doing where we're going to
do that but better
what's your opinion on the likelihood of
china just being so effective at this
that they do become
more and more and more powerful
so are you asking me more about what's
going to happen with the future of china
because essentially you described what
happens when china has essentially
global dominance uh
if the us
if the us doesn't
like if they decide okay no we don't
want to go the same route as china do
you think china's just going to
become world dominant yeah yeah yeah for
sure we see that already in europe you
know europe uh we've been criticized uh
that's where i am right now we've been
criticized as having the religion of
privacy right uh yeah you know the the
the new uh european commission's uh
regulations on ai once passed and you
know ratified uh does ban certain types
of ai things like facial recognition
thing uh particularly in high-risk
environments like law enforcement
because of issues of bias and so on
but there's different levels of risk
assessment and then
with those different levels there's also
different levels of regulation or ways
to actually address and govern those
technologies so we're taking a very kind
of middle road cautious approach the
united states if we are to believe these
documents if they're actually going to
act on these documents that we've seen
on the suggestions uh it seems that they
do want to surpass china in the
hypothetical that they don't i imagine
just the continual fall into decadence
of the united states and europe becoming
essentially the
uh playground for china where they come
to visit because it's beautiful and then
they go back
hmm
okay so then what
that's tricky
it's very tricky because when you have
someone who doesn't play by the same
rules what do you do i don't have an
answer for that it's a really tricky one
i'm not going to pretend to solve the
china issue
yeah definitely not okay then
yeah so what exactly can you give me
some details about what they're doing
over there
yeah so in the chinese state
ain't no stranger to the powers of huge
bodies with you know equally huge
influence like we have back in the
united states working with intelligence
communities you know google
so it's no wonder that seeing the
influence that big tech has on the west
china would crack down on how big tech
uses weights to influence its users like
uh using recommender systems and other
techniques that big tech giants have
used to you know rake in the money and
monopolize their power but china won't
suffer any other monopolistic powers
that's for sure
and they state that they have zero
tolerance for corrupt behaviors
particularly those giants that actively
try to consolidate power and capital
capital those trying to become
monopolies
obviously the thresholds for this are
super vague and we don't know how it's
actually being implemented in china on a
day-to-day basis it's you know quite
secretive and then we can't really trust
what comes out
still we see that the consequences in in
the west of the unhindered growth of
these giants we already talked about
that and how they become political
actors with their own agendas uh using
the users as currency you know there's
the same uh if uh if you're not paying
anything for example facebook well then
you're the product
and you know that's not to say that we
should adopt the china the chinese style
of crackdowns whatever that entails uh
i'm sure that would lead to a sort of
equally if not more detrimental over
correction that's usually what happens
when people react it's an over
correction
but i
you you hit on it something has to be
done i just don't know exactly
what the best ways to separate these
powers in the west are without risking
that you know extreme over correction of
just you know entirely dissolving them
okay
well
i'm going to let other people deal with
that problem i think i'm gonna i'm gonna
deal with something else that sounds a
little too complicated
definitely
that yeah that seems like a real problem
can you
after can you send me over links to
those documents we were talking about
earlier of course you said they're
online okay i'll post those in the show
notes yeah that's great wait this is
this is the only way right it's we've
got to get people to realize this to
push back small acts of rebellion right
not expecting revolutions but people say
no i i won't continue to use facebook i
won't be
uh their currency right i won't give
them the data that they'll then sell
uh then obviously to the intelligence
agencies also who have full access to
these uh to these systems so it's you
know making getting people informed and
this is this is one way
is there a way that you can like
you can give somebody your data and have
it not be a bad thing like is there any
future where the government
actually does something good with all
the data instead of becomes tyrannical
and
something terrible happens like i i mean
i assume that what they're doing and i
assume that they don't think they're
evil in china right they're like no this
is for the benefit of all our citizens
and there's going to be less suffering
this way
right but we're freaking out about it so
how do we know that it's bad
yeah
it's really
i guess the point of view you know no
other country in history has raised so
many people out of poverty in a single
generation
so you have to you have to ask the
question do the ends justify the means
i'm highly skeptical of the
centralization of power in general
particularly when
when everything is tied together in
terms of our personal data uh when it's
also tied to our ability to be
financially independent and autonomous
and these are the discussions that are
being had right now of centralizing our
ability to transact
with our vaccination status
um with our perhaps
what happens when you go to protest and
the government doesn't like that protest
well we see the consequence of that can
you imagine when all these things are
far simpler because they're unified into
a single system that they say it's going
to be highly secure that's horseshit
nothing is that secure someone can
always get in but that's not i'm not
worried about the people getting in i'm
worried about the watchers who are
actively using that
yeah no that's definitely scary because
like what if things need to change right
what if as a society we're doing
something wrong and you know how do you
even discover something new like you
probably know i've done a lot of work
with diet which goes completely against
mainstream
right so how and just using that as an
example if we're all centralized like
this what happens when there's an
outlier and they're like oh wait but
maybe we should do this differently it's
like no
cut that off
easily does not does that not seem
exactly the point
of these kinds of systems they keep
saying it's going to be so much more
convenient as if it's so difficult for
me to pull my license out of my wallet
you know it's so heavy to carry around
that i need a digital version of it so
now you have all my documents you have
the ability to access and to block my
bank accounts and then that's also tied
with whatever new vaccination status you
have whatever that is and then obviously
in terms of identifying people who hold
uh unacceptable views
right being targeted
when you have
the switch in your hand
so much easier
it seems like that's exactly the point
and we have the power in the east as a
essentially an example of how that's
being played out
okay so say these documents do get
implemented is there i mean you must
have thought about a timeline like how
long do we have before
we turn into another china
wow
i would say that if
if it's implemented the chinese style
system with these structural changes
as soon as those structural changes are
made
it's you've passed the event horizon
everything becomes centralized now can
we actually make that transition
i i'm not too sure i'm not too sure
people realize no we're not going to do
that i think that there's a certain
consciousness groin that's becoming
skeptical of these types of measures it
seems that perhaps governments within
the last year or so have pushed too far
rather than taking an inch they took a
meter right so that kind of works
against them you take one step at a time
and you're able to do that this was
hidden like i said i'm not sure if the
foia request was granted purposefully in
order to acclimatize people to the idea
right
you saber-rattle the people in the east
and you go look at if we don't even try
doing this with against them well then
we just become the you know the
playground for china
no simple answer but it is scary to
consider what would happen because
i don't trust the the nexis of power
hmm
okay
well
thank you very much for coming on my
podcast
that was much more interesting i
appreciate it was fun
yeah that was fun um if people want to
find you or any of your information
online where should they go
yeah you can just toss my name in google
you'll probably find uh my website
probably use duckduckgo even better
and my institutional sites if you're
interested in the academic work but uh
if you're interested in my forthcoming
book which was uh written for more
general audience like i mentioned before
it's called design for death controlling
killer robots about autonomous weapon
systems and you can check that out on
trivent publishings ethics and robotics
book series but if you want to follow me
on twitter you can do so with the handle
at stephen umbro and the iat with the
handle at iat
okay did you say your book was about
what did you say it was about autonomous
killing machines yeah autonomous weapons
yeah
okay
can you just describe what that is right
before we end it what does that mean
that sounds awful
yeah it does sound it does sound awful
so for years now this is kind of the
terminator scenario but the book tries
to get away from that terminator
scenario more generally because it gives
a bad idea of
uh what our autonomous weapon systems
are
and there's this trend towards more and
more autonomy within the warfare theater
and you know we've seen that since uh
the middle eastern wars the the trend
towards more and more drone strikes
seems that's the that's the norm rather
than the exception so the question of
what is a fully autonomous weapon system
it's well no longer does the human
actually physically control
uh the system in terms of target
selection and engagement but the system
is able to identify targets and then
engage them autonomously so that is what
an autonomous weapon system is and of
course there's different levels of
autonomy just like there's different
levels of autonomy even within a.i so
these are these are the questions that i
explore i try to find a middle path
because uh my the argument in the book
is that if we just try to ban these out
right like go no no autonomous weapon
systems whatsoever then those states
that are designing them simply won't
sign the international agreements and
use them anyway but if we find the
middle path of say maybe these ones we
shouldn't do and these ones are
acceptable if we design them for values
like the laws of armed conflict then
maybe those state actors who have an
interest in developing these types of
systems will be more likely to sign on
to these international treaties and
respect them
okay i like that seems like a that seems
like a good thing to write hopefully the
bad guys read it
okay thank you again for coming on that
was enjoyable
[Music]
you